what goes through your mind when someone
tells you you can't do something
[Laughter]
i will say that there's like
there's still a little teeny part of me
that aunt like the answer's first in my
mind
and says oh yeah they're right like even
with all the work i do there's still
like this teeny tiny part but i
i quiet very quickly and
um i just don't accept that for myself
i and because because there's always
going to be proof that
that's not true for everybody or
everything you know that's why i say
to look for absolutes when they're
saying words like always or never
that'll never work or you can't do that
you know but there's always going to be
an exception to that
right so so i can't i can't take that on
as my own
and even if it even if no proof existed
and it was something new that i was
trying to do
i still have to believe that it's
possible i still have to get behind that
um regardless so usually if somebody
tells me that
they're either someone that i'm not
gonna work with moving forward
or um you know i might try to educate
them
on my philosophy you know how i view
things but
you know in the in the industry i i
still do hear it a lot
yeah can you talk about limiting beliefs
and how we
live someone else's reality this is
where i want to talk about
realistic i think that um
what somebody else deems as realistic
is based upon their belief system
and they might be limited in that scope
you know they might have a limiting
belief about what is realistic
and the way that our subconscious mind
works
is that if we believe them
that means we're deciding that what
they're saying is true
then it gets stored in a subconscious
but if we don't believe them then it
doesn't get stored in our subconscious
and so we have to get more aware
and vigilant about what we allow into
our
subconscious because if we don't we will
end up living somebody else's version of
what they think is realistic you know
based on their limiting beliefs so for
example
you know as an entrepreneur myself
starting a business
and wanting to own a home and you know
in the hills or by the ocean that's
going to be a multi-million dollar home
so if i want to you know buy a
multi-million dollar home
i have to believe that it's realistic
for that to happen
for me to buy a multi-million dollar
home
and the way that i do that is
by looking for proof and for ways of how
to make that
tangibly happen like if i can learn more
about what it takes to own a
multi-million dollar home what does my
income need to be you know i spoke to
realtors i spoke to lenders i
you know i learned about the process of
you know how much would i put down
you know people that are buying at that
level are they paying cash you know
i really had to learn all of these
things and the more i learned it the
more it becomes more realistic because
i understand what it takes right so as
i have grown as a business owner as an
entrepreneur
i started to know people you know i
started to expand my
friend base of other entrepreneurs who
are further along
than me financially right so for example
one of my friends last year just hit her
first million dollar a year
so a million dollars in a year that's
like 83
000 a month right
now most people would say 83
000 a month that's not realistic
right some people aren't even making
that per year
and so we decide that that isn't
realistic but to my friend who has done
it
it's totally realistic to her she did it
so her reality is not the same of
somebody else's reality because she
believe you know she believes in a
different
definition of what is realistic
and if we look at it it's totally
realistic for her to make 83 000
a month it's also totally realistic for
her to incrementally grow
every year and make more than that you
know it is not that far off for her to
make a hundred thousand dollars a month
her one of her mentors has made up to
four hundred thousand dollars a month
again it sounds like something that's
not realistic
right and you could say oh well she got
lucky or she won the lottery
no they're just entrepreneurs that
learned how to build a business
and and actually jack canfield says in
that book the success principles that
a millionaire is made every four minutes
i believe
in the united states so it's much more
common
than we realize but in our mind tells us
it's not realistic
so if i want to be a millionaire or if i
want to own a multi-million dollar home
and that means that i need to have an
income
you know past a million i can't take on
somebody else's belief that says i can't
do that
i can't listen to someone that says
erica that's not really realistic
right i can't take that on because if i
do it'll never happen i'll never get
that house
so instead i have to surround myself
with people like my friend who
who's already now hitting a million
dollars a year and seeing how she's
doing it and learning from her
and going oh okay totally realistic
so i'm deciding that what i want even
though it might sound
crazy to other people is actually really
realistic to me
you know and so i i have to decide that
for myself and i i can't
base my belief on what someone else's
belief is
ah
that sounds like a nice that sounds
really nice
how can an artist ruin their own career
because they're living someone else's
fear-based reality
well i mean with my example
of the house if i take on someone else's
limiting belief that this is impossible
i
i ruined the dream by not even if i
don't even believe it could happen
i'm not going to learn how to grow my
income
i'm not going to speak to a lender and
learn what a lender is going to need
from me as an entrepreneur who doesn't
bring home w-2s every day
every week you know like all of that
research that i've done
i wouldn't do that research if i take on
their beliefs
so you know i don't know if ruin is the
word that i would use that they're
ruining their career
but i think that they're you're always
going to get what you believe
so if you take on somebody else's belief
that this can't happen or you can't have
that
that's exactly what you will get so
um it'll i guess ruin you know any
chances of having the thing that you
desire if
you're not believing that you can have
it how do we get in tune with our own
reality
in tune with your own reality meaning in
tune with the reality you want to create
like whatever you want to be realistic
for yourself
that's true because i guess we could get
in tune with our own reality that's
negative like basically you never want
to get in tune with your reality
like your reality is not having what you
want
right like like right now in my reality
i don't have the house
so i don't want to get in tune with that
reality i want to get in tune with the
reality in which i have the house
so i mean abraham hicks talks about this
a lot but it's really about like stop
focusing on what you don't have you know
abraham says that every subject is
really two subjects
the having it and then not having it so
if you want to book a show
you're either focused on the fact that
you haven't booked it yet and don't have
it or you're focused on the fact
that you're going to have it right
and so one of those is the dominant
thought there
and so you don't want to focus on the
reality that you don't have it
you want to focus on the reality you're
creating in the future
in the near future so you really want to
get in tune with the reality that you
want to create
you know from a law of attraction
standpoint and you know talk
terms of like manifesting whatever is in
your life right now
you have created you have manifested
so everything you have now is based on
things you've done in the past
and so the same for the future things
that you want is going to be based on
what you're doing right now so what
you're doing right now oh it's talking
about getting in alignment with the
thing that you want
what do we do now to manifest that thing
in the future
we get aligned with it meaning we
believe
that we're going to have it you know we
stop focusing on lack
stop focusing on what we don't have and
we just get excited about it we
visualize
we focus on how it's going to feel it's
really about the feeling so
when i have this job i'm going to feel
really excited
and really confident and really proud
okay well can i experience those
emotions
right now totally you don't need to book
a job to feel excited
you can get excited right you can create
that emotion for yourself so it's about
like how can i just focus on feeling
excited and confident
and proud right and that is going to
call this in
as opposed to if i got in tune with my
current reality where i don't have
the job i might feel sad i might feel
frustrated
i might feel not worthy right and all of
those things and
and when we focus on those feelings and
by the way this is not to say that it's
bad to feel those feelings like i always
tell my clients
it's healthy and okay to feel whatever
comes up for you
it's just about can we shorten the time
in which we don't feel good
and shift into feeling better so
it's getting aligned with those feelings
and belief in what's coming and
expecting it
you